music is love that you want to share
with other people and that's really that
the voice is the voice is back for
Season eight and our Brooke Anderson
chatted with coach Pharrell Williams
fresh off a very powerful performance at
the Grammys Sunday night on the very
beginning there was the breath that was
metaphorical and then after that there
was the hands up that was metaphorical
and then there were hoodies in there as
well that was metaphorical
but it was all meant just as a
acknowledgement of a lot of the things
that have been happening we want to make
sure people understand we've seen it we
hear it and we're knowledge in it and we
just want to bring light to it positive
light he's returning to the coach's
chair at the end of the month
alongside Blake Shelton Adam Levine and
Christina Aguilera these guys are like
brothers it's like coming home to very
oddly dysfunctional awesome family
Christina takes Gwen's chair on the
voice she's back after a maternity break
but her five-month old at home is no
match for Blake and Adams vapor nursery
here on set Carson has a nursery for me
Blake to it you need a nursery you need
a little place yeah definitely fire she
actually has four milk if you include
myself but I don't I don't feed you know
that'll be weird I think that you would
be awesome on Adams team oh you did not
like this I like that I wonder who the
mama okay those two are kids I wonder
who that I wonder who starts you know
who puts a little bit more milk in one
bottle in it
I wonder who does get the high jinks
ensue when the voice returns February
23rd on NBC
you